we begin with breaking news from Vietnam
or the second summit between President
Trump and North Korean dictator Kim
jong-un is officially underway they are
sitting down to dinner right now after
another historic handshake and a brief
one-on-one meeting the two leaders want
to make progress on denuclearization
after their first summit in Singapore
last year the president says that North
Korea could benefit greatly from a deal
[Music]
mr. Trump will have a major distraction
at home his former lawyer and personal
fixer Michael Cohen speaks out this
morning on Capitol Hill the president
tweeted that Cohen quote did bad things
unrelated to Trump he is lying in order
to reduce his prison time Face the
Nation moderator and senior senior
foreign affairs correspondent Margaret
Brennan is at the summit in Hanoi
Vietnam Margaret good morning good
morning to you John
well that dinner that the two leaders
are having will help determine the tone
of negotiations tomorrow we saw the two
together for the first time tonight
since their historic encounter in
Singapore some eight months ago and
since that time neither side has even
agreed to what denuclearizing North
Korea actually means the goal of this
summit is to draft a roadmap and sketch
out the specific next steps so once
again president Trump is granting Kim
jong-un a prominent position on
world stage so far that is all the US
has offered North Korean officials
complain that they have given up more
than they've gotten having caused
nuclear and missile tests for more than
a year but it continues to develop its
nuclear program meanwhile in the past
weeks the State Department led by
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo and
negotiators Steve vegan have been trying
to nail down specific commitments ahead
of this meeting and I am told there has
been progress but it has been slow on
the table right now the u.s. is
considering a number of offers including
opening a diplomatic liaison office in
Pyongyang to keep communication channels
open taking North Korea off the state
sponsors of terrorism list even floating
the idea of a peace agreement to
formally end the state of war but all
those things are possibilities and not
promises